Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
Supernatural brought back and old friend to
make things right and paid off a really important
plot point setup back in season 8’s Taxi
Driver Episode.
It also kind of showed us Dean is the world’s
worst Ghost Whisperer.
Didn’t he learn anything from Ghostfacers?
I’ll also be including bits about the Spin
Off show Tribes after we speechify this episode.
I’m also doing a special Fandom Oscars Event
this weekend.
Be sure to subscribe to participate.
It’s going to be fun.
I’ll do a video to announce what the awards
are so you guys can nominate shows, movies
and people.
It’s going to be just like Fantasy Football
with sci-fi and fantasy shows and movies.
So for this episode let’s do our top 5 moments,
then I’ll do my review and talk about the
spin off show.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Number 5 - Castiel Versus Bartholomew.
Sure he had the B-storyline this week, but
it was a really nice twist to make the evil-ish
angel Bartholomew Castiel’s former comrade
in arms.
If you haven’t seen it yet, the whole Raphael
war they’re talking about was from Season
6 which is on Netflix, but the whole exchange
they had seemed like it was setting Castiel
up to become the new God either at the end
of this season or in season 10.
Not in the way he was during Season 7, but
a new wiser more benevolent leader.
With a lot more city miles on him.
I don’t know about you guys, but I totally
wasn’t surprised when those other angels
showed up to follow him at the end of the
episode.
Meet the newest faction in the War for heaven.
Let me know what you think we should call
them.
Number 4 - Tiger Mom Electrician.
So it was funny to see her author her own
escape via the electrical panel and Sam’s
reaction.
But based on the timeline I feel like she
would have at least almost escaped a few times.
I mean she is Tiger Mom, she’s not going
to just sit there.
They didn’t acknowledge attempted breakouts.
But I think it’s implied that she’s chained
to the opposite wall because she’s almost
escaped several times.
If you’re smart enough to Macgyver a control
panel you should totally be able to pick a
lock.
Number 3 - Tiger Mom part 2, Revenge of the
Tiger Mom.
I loved the setup for her killing Demon Del,
I knew he was working with Crowley and had
clearly gone fruitloops, but I didn’t realize
he was a demon till she stabbed him.
So for most of that exchange I thought she
was going to revenge murder him.
Number 2 - Tran Family Reunion.
It had been teased for the entire episode
and was a huge payoff to Crowley’s lie that
he killed her back in Season 8.
I love that as dark as Supernatural gets,
it kind of takes some of the worst things
back.
The big tease at the end though was that Kevin’s
spirit is going to start to get twisted from
staying on earth too long.
his mom acknowledges it, and as happy as the
moment was.
There was this really dark overtone.
and my Number 1 moment - Kevin comes back.
I separated this from the reunion just because
it was the biggest surprise of the episode.
I was a little blown away that they revealed
him as the ghost so quickly.
And at how quickly they brushed over Sam killing
him.
Kevin seemed like he was totally over it and
just happy to carry on in his old role of
sending them on missions.
Albeit for a slightly more personal one this
time.
Bringing him back was such a huge thing that
I was surprised they didn’t tease and haunted
bunker moments in previous episodes since
the show has been back this year.
But the good news is that until they fix heaven,
Kevin is stuck on earth.
So you know he’ll be in another episode.
Now it’s your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was and how else do you think
ghost Kevin is going to help them this season?
Overall I gave the episode a solid B plus
for paying off two important plot points with
the Kevin story and teasing a major shift
in the Castiel character and the war for Heaven.
Bonus points for getting rid of Bartholomew,
he was a total dick.
More to the Castiel story, I always kind of
view him as the conscience of the show.
The one that actually considers the moral
implications of what they’re doing.
So I think Misha Collins did a great job of
showing with his performance that Castiel
totally understands that he’s probably going
to end up having to be God or at least the
leader of Heaven again.
The factions are really just the first step.
Eventually his will get bigger and regardless
of how it happens.
He’ll be in charge eventually.
I think they’re trying to imply that this
time it will be for the better.
The only things I thought could have been
better were drawing out the Kevin reveal till
the end of the episode instead of at the beginning
and Dean felt like he almost didn’t belong
in the episode.
If they had dropped maybe five of his lines
Sam could have done the whole mission by himself.
Now let’s talk some spin off!
They’ve finally cast the leads for Tribes.
Just like the original, there are two leads.
Lucien Laviscount and Nathanien Buzolic.
They’re going to air a backdoor pilot episode
on April 29th as a regular Supernatural episode.
It will introduce the characters and set up
what the series main arc will be in it’s
first season.
The show is going to be centered in Chicago
and will be like a noir-ish monster mafia
crime drama.
Like The Untouchables with Monsters.
Or you could even compare it to the way Joss
Whedon’s Angel worked in and around Los
Angeles with all the different monster/demon
factions.
Here’s some details about their characters.
Laviscount will play Ennis Roth a police officer
who’s finacee is killed in a monster mafia
turf war.
He dedicates himself to ridding Chicago of
monsters.
And co-star Buzolic will play David Hayden,
a shape-shifter from one of the most powerful
monster families.
He’s given up that life and has been living
as a human, he’ll team up with Ennis to
help him clean up the city.
Like I said, this will all play out in an
hour long episode on April 29th.
Remember Fandom Oscars coming up this week,
I’ll try to post that first video tomorrow.
Right now click here for my last Supernatural
video and click here to learn all about the
new Flash spinoff show with Grant Gustin.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!